it is what it was and it's my mistake
and I paid for it
he wasn't responsive because when I ran
up to him you know I didn't think he was
alive
Jeremy Renner and his nephew Alex open
up for the first time about the snow
plow accident that nearly took the
actor's life
someone's been run over by a snow cat
hurry he's been crushed okay we have one
paramedic to ambulance everybody's on
the way right now listen to me you might
want to get a life flight out here
immediately the neighbors who called
9-1-1 nearly lost hope I really feel he
did pass away for a couple seconds I
really do I I knew it was Dire and I was
like I don't know if he's gonna make
this one Jeremy sits down with Diane
Sawyer for an ABC News special where he
speaks candidly about the near fatal
January accident during an attempt to
save Alex's life Alex is here the truck
is right behind him he's gonna get
sandwiched by this and the truck says I
try to jump back in the dang dang dip
right yeah disengaging yeah is is pretty
terrifying to uh to see like you know
the person that you look up to for so
much
um
to be like that to see them like that
and then his head kind of turned and
then like this huge breath came back
into him Jeremy was run over by a
seven-ton snow plow on New Year's Day
his sister Kim Renner rushed to his side
I was the first to arrive at the
hospital and I saw
um
one of the scariest things I've ever
seen
a poor sister
we don't know if they're swelling on his
brain we don't know if his heart's still
working can he breathe on his own the
accident left him in critical condition
with 30 plus broken bones Jeremy also
had to undergo surgery for blunt chest
trauma and Orthopedic injuries do you
remember the pain oh all of it yeah I
was awake through every moment and it's
a it's exactly like you imagined it
would feel like it had a chance to chat
yeah no been in touch with him reached
out to me soon good I believe and oh
yeah all prayers are with him since the
accident Jeremy's friends and co-stars
have shared updates with E.T
I talked to him yesterday yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah he's he's doing all right he's
doing he's doing well he's the best best
guy and you know
um he's awesome
the key is a force in nature he's
Unstoppable and I just am so relieved
that he's on the comeback Trail and
Jeremy has shared updates
that was the first shower
I'm definitely a week or so gross
the actor posted that video with his mom
and sister just days after the accident
was seriously cool and you're totally
doing the walking motion crap yeah and
just with only um 40 of my weight
shared that clip from a recent physical
therapy session walking on an assisted
treadmill I refuse to have
that be a trauma and be a negative
experience
that
is a man I'm proud of I am refused to be
haunted
by that memory that way now Jeremy says
he's got a new lease on life that won't
keep him down do you dream of doing
those stats again
I'm okay with a stunt guy doing it
support him 52. it's fine I've done
enough I'm okay to do more right but you
know I'm okay I have no ego like yeah go
for it I don't care I'll be in my
trailer